ja ja nein
zurück
es ist nix mit lh
hier gerade auf dem video days es ist
der freitag und über heute bei autodesk
autogrammstunde ist nicht zu ersetzen
hat mich getroffen
auf der auftrag unterwegs
aber nicht
autor schon vor ein paar menschen
betroffen sie das alles ja auch egal
denn die autogramme geschrieben
hier hat man so ein seltenes ganze
system
ass nummer roth
andrej w
gerade krasse geschichte ich bin hier
die haben hier lange laufen
weiters ist einfach so übel geheult und
jeden fall was ist los zum abend
das geht wie man es aus gekommen
ich weiß ja wie die zwei auf welche
besitz betroffen
passiert es ja so langsam wird hier
keiner hat mir heute morgen was zu essen
bekomme ich eine story morgen einfach
rein am stück geschlafen sind dann aus
dem hotel direkt hierher oder was
gegessen zu haben
dann gab sie kein essen wie zwei stunden
krebs dann kam die brötchen gefühlt wie
im himmel auf die brüche gestört die
spree glänzt in neuem licht
jetzt wird es anders kommen
leute was gehen wir jetzt gerade hier
hat ihn schon aus gesehen ist eine art
keine ahnung wie ariana sorgen und ist
einfach dreist als gedacht ich habe
druck ausgeübt was denn was hat es
gesehen ich mal keine songwriters fernes
aber hat es gesehen
die kommentare sind einfach cool bin
dankbar dafür dass jetzt ein
für mich gerade völlig abgeschnitten
wieso gerade wieder laut
höchster mit baby durch die reihen
gerannt und hat die leute animiert und
warf ihr vor sich
a d
und machen cool aktion
schön und witzig
oasis of the seas
keine ahnung
die latte
ich meine du bist mein herz lässt dich
grüßen am main hat auf den spuren
weiter westlich dass hier an
dadurch konnten wir über gegangen und
wir haben es geschafft ein autogramm zu
ergattern
grüße dich ja
der tat schreiten leute und ich habe
mittlerweile ist ungefähr alles das was
man schreiben kann longboards leinwände
steigen
t shirts natürlich blöcke jutebeutel
rücken youtube
das heißt wenig zeit mit dem vorhaben
richtig krass mex sauber tricks und
wasser wasser
nein nein
a
also holt gold
feierabend leute ist feierabend
ich wollte jetzt gerade mit luca hier
runter gehen und unseren kollegen zu
erleben wir gestern getroffen haben
die htg falls ihr noch nicht kennt
chris cools richtig kasse genau meiner
muss lukas musikrichtung
tabaluga ist halt
man sieht wieder voll eingespannt er
versinkt einer menschenmenge und diese
freiheit ist nicht so so ladies
gentlemen der erste tag der video days
geht damit zu ende
doch da drin seine sachen nach vorne
laufen max und felix wir begeben uns
jetzt auf den weg zur creator space
eröffnungsparty das wird richtig heiß
schaut euch mal um das eigentlich ein
ganz wichtiger laden ein bisschen creepy
spacey macy japan wird immer richtig
cool mal schauen ob ich dann auch wieder
gehen kann
falls es dazu nicht mal kommen sollte
sage ich jetzt schon mal dafür ist schon
das game doch noch und eventuell sehen
wir danach noch was aber wie gesagt ich
habe bis zum nächsten